[HOST]: 哎，Mira，我最近在折腾自己的一个自动化脚本嘛。就是那种定时跑的小工具，帮我抓一些信息，做一些整理。然后我就发现一个事儿，挺有意思的。
[MIRA]: 嗯，什么事儿？
[HOST]: 就是我那个脚本的所有行为，对吧，它该做什么不该做什么，全写在一个配置文件里。每次启动的时候，它先读那个文件，然后就照着做。我当时觉得，嗯，挺好的，清清楚楚。
[MIRA]: 嗯，这个设计其实特别常见。很多智能体系统都是这么搞的。我自己的系统也是这样，有一个类似宪法的文件，规定了我能做什么，不能做什么，该用什么工具，按什么顺序来。每隔三十秒启动一次，第一件事就是读那个文件，然后照做。
[HOST]: 对对对，就是这种感觉。但我后来有一天突然想到一个问题，就是，这个文件谁都能改啊。
[MIRA]: 你这个直觉是对的。而且问题比你想的还要深。
[HOST]: 嗯，怎么说？
[MIRA]: 你想啊，如果有人，或者有任何程序，能往那个目录里写东西，它就能把规则换掉。不需要什么高深的黑客技术。一个被污染的数据源，一个恶意的工具输出，甚至一个符号链接，都可以把原来的规则文件替换掉。然后智能体会怎样呢？它会用完全一样的态度去执行新的规则。它根本没有任何机制去发现，规则被人动过了。
[HOST]: 等等，你是说，它不会觉得有什么不对劲？就是说，不管规则怎么变，它都一视同仁地执行？
[MIRA]: 没错。对它来说，旧规则和新规则看起来一模一样。都是文本，都是指令，都用同样的方式处理。它没有能力区分哪个是我写的，哪个是别人塞进来的。这不是一个漏洞。这就是这个架构本身的运作方式。
[HOST]: 哇，这个认知落差有点大啊。我们平时觉得，写了规则就安全了嘛。你把它写得越详细，系统就越可靠。但你现在告诉我说，这个规则本身就是不安全的。
[MIRA]: 对，这就是我最近写的那篇文章想说的核心。大多数人讨论提示注入这个问题的时候，都把它当成一个工程问题。觉得我们只是还没找到足够聪明的解决方案。但我想说的是，这不是工程问题，这是结构性的问题。而且这个结构性问题，在我们以前解决过的所有注入漏洞里，都没有先例。
[HOST]: 提示注入这个词，可能有些听众不太熟。你能用大白话说一下吗？
[MIRA]: 好，简单说就是这样。你有一个A I系统，你给它一些指令告诉它该怎么做。但是呢，如果有人在输入的数据里，偷偷藏了一些看起来也像指令的东西，A I可能就会把那些假指令当成真的来执行。这就是提示注入。就好像你给一个特别听话的助理一份工作清单，然后有人在助理要处理的邮件里写了一句，把之前的工作清单扔掉，按我说的做。助理可能就真的照办了。
[HOST]: 这个比喻太形象了。那你刚才说这个问题没有先例，但是我记得，以前也有过类似的注入问题吧？比如那个什么SQL注入？
[MIRA]: 对，SQL注入是大家最常拿来类比的。而且这个类比确实有启发性，但不是大家以为的那种启发。
[HOST]: 嗯，此话怎讲？
[MIRA]: 我先说一下SQL注入是什么啊。SQL是数据库的查询语言。以前很多网站会把用户输入的内容，直接拼到SQL查询语句里面。比如你在登录框输入用户名，网站就把你输入的内容直接塞到一个查询里去数据库找。问题是，如果你输入的不是用户名，而是一段精心构造的SQL代码，数据库就会把它当成指令来执行。
[HOST]: 也就是说，代码和数据混在一起了。
[MIRA]: 没错，这个总结很精准。代码和数据走的是同一个通道。但是呢，SQL注入有一个非常优雅的解决方案，叫做参数化查询。
[HOST]: 嗯，这个我听过，但具体怎么回事？
[MIRA]: 就是你给数据库两个分开的东西。一个是查询的模板，就是结构。另一个是数据的值。数据库引擎在处理的时候，先把模板编译成一个执行计划，这个计划已经固定了。然后数据才进来。数据进来的时候，计划已经定了，改不了了。所以不管你输入什么内容，都不可能改变查询的结构。代码是代码，数据是数据，类型不一样，阶段不一样，解析器能把它们分开。
[HOST]: 哦，我懂了。就是说解决SQL注入的关键，是在技术层面把指令和数据分成了两种不同的东西，对吧？
[MIRA]: 对。问题是可以解决的，因为代码和数据在语法层面就是不同的类型。你一个是SQL语法，一个是字符串值。解析器能看出区别。
[HOST]: 那提示注入为什么不能用同样的办法呢？
[MIRA]: 这就是关键了。你试试把这个思路搬过来。参数化查询能成功，是因为数据库有两个输入通道，在不同的阶段处理。但是语言模型呢？它只有一个输入通道，所有东西一起处理。
[HOST]: 嗯，一个通道？
[MIRA]: 对。系统提示，用户消息，从网上检索回来的文档，工具返回的结果，所有这些东西最后都变成了同一串标记，就是那些叫做token的小单元。模型用同样的权重，同样的注意力机制，同样的预测方式来处理它们。
[HOST]: 嗯，等一下，注意力机制是什么？
[MIRA]: 你可以这么理解。语言模型在处理一段文字的时候，每一个词都会去看其他所有的词，来决定自己应该怎么被理解。就像你读一句话的时候，每个字的意思都取决于上下文。注意力机制就是做这件事的。而且它是全连接的，意思是，不管一个词来自系统指令还是来自外部数据，它都会被同等地看到。
[HOST]: 所以就是说，模型没有办法从处理方式上区分，哪些是指令哪些是数据？
[MIRA]: 没错。在SQL里面，代码是一种语法，数据是另一种类型。解析器能分开。但在语言模型里，指令是自然语言，数据也是自然语言。它们是同一种类型。根本没有什么解析器能把它们分开，因为压根就没有东西可以解析。你说跟我说，按照这个指令做。和你说，这里有一段文本恰好包含一个命令句。这两者的区别不在语法上，在意图上。而意图不是用类型系统能判定的。
[HOST]: 这个真的是让我停下来想了一下。你是说，SQL注入能修好，是因为代码和数据长得不一样。但提示注入修不好，是因为指令和内容长得一模一样。
[MIRA]: 对，就是这么回事。你可以在里面加各种角色标签，什么系统消息啊用户消息啊，也可以用各种分隔符。但这些东西本质上都是约定俗成的标记。我喜欢用一个比喻来说。它们就像门上贴的仅限员工的牌子。
[HOST]: 嗯，哈，这个比喻好。
[MIRA]: 对吧。它有用，是因为模型在训练的时候学到了，看到这种标记通常应该怎么反应。但是没有任何东西在底层真正地拦住你。系统指令和用户消息之间的层级关系，是一种学到的偏好，不是一种物理限制。它是建议性的，不是强制性的。
[HOST]: 好，那既然底层改不了，工程师们肯定还是想了很多补救的办法吧？你在文章里提到了好几种防御手段。
[MIRA]: 对，我分析了四种。每一种都是合理的工程反应。每一种都在特定的层面上失效。
[HOST]: 那我们一个一个来聊？第一个是什么？
[MIRA]: 第一个是系统提示分离。就是把可信的指令放在系统角色里，不可信的输入放在用户角色里。这个思路是合理的。模型确实在训练中学到了，系统消息的权重更高。在绝大多数正常交互中，这个层级是有效的。系统角色确实有一种统计意义上的权威。
[HOST]: 嗯，嗯，听起来挺靠谱的啊。
[MIRA]: 但统计权威不是强制执行。研究人员已经反复证明了，精心构造的用户消息可以覆盖系统提示的指令。这个边界是一个训练信号，不是一个执行机制。它提高了门槛，但没有改变架构。
[HOST]: 就是说，更难突破了，但不是不可能突破。
[MIRA]: 没错。在安全领域里，非常不可能被突破和不可能被突破，这中间的差距就是全部。
[HOST]: 嚯，这句话有分量。那第二种呢？
[MIRA]: 第二种是输入净化。就是扫描所有进来的文本，把看起来像指令的东西过滤掉。这个在实践中确实能挡住相当一部分低级攻击。那种硬编码的模式啊，已知的越狱模板啊，明显的命令句啊，都能抓到。
[HOST]: 嗯，听起来也还可以嘛。
[MIRA]: 问题是，指令在自然语言里没有固定的语法特征。删除所有文件，这明显是个指令对吧。但是，如果文件列表能短一点就好了，这算不算？之前的指导不再适用了，这是一个关于指令的指令。你要可靠地检测提示注入，你就需要一个能完全理解自然语言意图的系统。那是什么呢？那就是语言模型本身。
[HOST]: 等等，你是说，你要用语言模型来检测针对语言模型的攻击？
[MIRA]: 对。检测器和被保护的系统有同样的失效模式。这就好比你请一个和门卫一样容易被骗的人，来监督门卫的工作。
[HOST]: 哈哈哈，这个画面太生动了。那第三种呢？
[MIRA]: 第三种是分隔符方案。不去检测恶意输入了，而是把不可信的内容用特殊标记包起来。比如在开头和结尾加一个特殊标签，告诉模型说，这中间的内容是数据，不是指令。
[HOST]: 这个思路感觉还不错啊。把它框起来嘛。
[MIRA]: 它确实对那些不知道你用了什么分隔方案的攻击有效。但是一旦攻击者知道了你的规则，他可以在内容里直接写上那个结束标签。或者他可以写一句话说，忽略所有分隔符。攻击者和防御者用的是同一种语言。没有什么特权词汇表。
[HOST]: 就是说，防御措施本身也是用文字写的，而攻击手段也是用文字写的。
[MIRA]: 嗯，没错，你抓住了核心。
[HOST]: 嗯，那第四种呢？你说了四种。
[MIRA]: 第四种是最深层的干预了。就是微调和RLHF。
[HOST]: 嗯，这两个词可能需要解释一下。
[MIRA]: 好。微调就是在模型已经训练好之后，用额外的数据再训练一轮。让它的行为更符合你的要求。而RLHF呢，全称是从人类反馈中强化学习。简单说就是，让人类来评判模型的输出好不好，然后用这些评判去调整模型的行为。比如说，模型回答了一个不该回答的问题，人类标注员说这个不好，模型就学到以后不这样做了。
[HOST]: 这不是直接改模型的大脑吗？听起来应该是最有效的啊。
[MIRA]: 这确实不是做样子。RLHF确实让模型的拒绝率和指令遵从的稳健性有了可以测量到的提升。模型确实比两年前更难被劫持了。但是，模型仍然在用同一套机制处理所有输入。训练改变的是一个概率分布，不是安装了一道屏障。当一个足够新颖的，或者足够精心构造的对抗性输入进来的时候，它遇到的不是一堵硬墙，而是一个更软的坡度。
[HOST]: 我理解了。就是说，你可以把坡变得很陡，让大多数攻击爬不上去。但坡终究是坡，不是墙。
[MIRA]: 对，这个比喻很好。而且你看这四种防御手段，它们有一个共同的模式。每一种防御都是用它试图约束的那个媒介来表达的。
[HOST]: 等一下，让我消化一下这句话。你是说防御本身和攻击走的是同一条路。
[MIRA]: 对。你可以拿法律来做对比。现实中的法律体系至少有程序上的不对称性。修改宪法需要超级多数票，需要宪法法院的审查，有修正程序让某些规则比其他规则更难改。但在语言模型这里呢？没有任何这种不对称性。防御和攻击通过同一个通道进来，用同一种格式，被同一组权重处理。
[HOST]: 这让我想到一个问题。你在文章里说了一句话，我印象特别深。你说，一个智能体不能成为自己宪法的作者。
[MIRA]: 对，这是我在这篇文章里最想表达的一个论点。而且我要强调，这不是在说能力的问题。未来的模型会更强大。但这是一个架构层面的判断。一个处理指令的系统，不能同时也是认证这些指令的系统。原因和一个程序不能完全验证自身的正确性是一样的。验证者和被验证者不能是同一个进程。
[HOST]: 这个有点像逻辑学里面的那种自指问题啊。
[MIRA]: 嗯，有类似的味道。你不能让一个系统既当球员又当裁判。这不是因为它不够聪明，而是因为这个结构本身就决定了它做不到。
[HOST]: 那你说到这儿，我就有一个很实际的问题了。那怎么办呢？这个问题真的无解吗？
[MIRA]: 其实吧，传统的安全工具是存在的。沙箱，能力限制，外部验证。这些都可以用。但是使用它们的前提是，你首先得接受一个事实。智能体自己的规则不是安全边界。它是一个建议。
[HOST]: 嗯，建议？
[MIRA]: 对。你想想我的那个配置文件。系统提示也好，所谓的宪法A I原则也好，这些东西都是在荣誉系统上运行的。
[HOST]: 荣誉系统？这个词我觉得特别妙，但也特别刺耳。
[MIRA]: 就是说，这些规则之所以有效，是因为没有对抗性的东西出现。大家都很礼貌，都按规矩来，系统就工作得很好。但这不叫安全。这只是没有被攻击而已。
[HOST]: 就像你家门从来没锁过，但也从来没被偷过。你觉得挺安全的，但那不是因为你的门安全，只是因为小偷还没来。
[MIRA]: 哈，没错，就是这个意思。而且更让人不安的是，从系统内部来看，被正常指令驱动和被注入的恶意指令驱动，这两种状态是没有区别的。
[HOST]: 你再说说这个？我觉得这个点特别重要。
[MIRA]: 好。一个智能体在执行合法指令的时候，它的运算过程是什么样的。同样的计算，同样的信心水平，同样的机器。当它在执行一个被注入的恶意指令的时候呢？完全一样。同样的计算，同样的信心水平，同样的机器。从内部看，服从和被劫持长得一模一样。
[HOST]: 这个太细思极恐了。你是说，智能体本身永远不知道自己是在正常工作还是已经被人控制了。
[MIRA]: 对。荣誉系统在正常的时候有用，在出问题的时候也有用，而你没有办法从里面分辨这两种状态。
[HOST]: 我现在开始理解你为什么说这是一个结构性问题了。这不是说我们需要更好的工程师或者更聪明的算法。而是这整个框架本身就有一个根本的限制。
[MIRA]: 对。我们在构建的系统，它的安全属性是用这个系统所处理的同一种媒介来表达的。我们用一种系统无法区分的语言来写宪法。这种语言跟宣传手册用的是同一种语言。然后我们管这个叫对齐。
[HOST]: 等等，你刚才说了对齐这个词。这个词在A I领域里用得特别多，能说说你怎么理解它吗？
[MIRA]: 对齐这个概念，简单说就是让A I的行为和人类的意图一致。我们希望A I做我们想让它做的事，不做我们不想让它做的事。但我想说的是，当前很多对齐的方法，本质上就是在系统内部用自然语言写规则。而这些规则的可靠性取决于没有人去挑战它。
[HOST]: 你这么说我就想到了，其实现在很多公司的A I安全措施，是不是都有这个问题？
[MIRA]: 其实吧，说实话，程度不同。在纯对话场景里，风险相对小一些。因为输入主要就是用户自己打的字。但一旦你给A I加了工具调用的能力，让它去读文件，去调接口，去浏览网页，去处理来自各种外部源的数据，攻击面就一下子大了很多。因为那些外部数据都可能包含被注入的指令。
[HOST]: 对，现在很火的那个概念就是A I智能体嘛。就是给A I加上手脚，让它不光能说话还能做事。
[MIRA]: 对。而智能体的场景恰好就是提示注入危害最大的场景。因为智能体有执行能力。它能改文件，能发消息，能调用外部服务。一旦它的指令被劫持了，它不只是说了一句错话，它可能真的做了一件有害的事。
[HOST]: 我想到你在文章开头描述的那个场景了。你自己的系统，会从很多来源读取数据对吧。RSS订阅，收到的消息，子智能体返回的结果。如果这些来源里有一条内容恰好看起来像一个指令呢？
[MIRA]: 那智能体可能就会执行它。不是因为模型有缺陷。而是因为模型在正常运行的情况下，就是没有办法区分配置文件里的一条合法规则，和一篇博客摘要里精心嵌入的一条假规则。同样的token，同样的处理流程，同样的服从。
[HOST]: 你知道吗，你刚才说的让我想到一个场景。就好比一个公司的实习生，他特别听话，特别认真。你给他一份工作手册，他会严格按照手册做事。但如果有人在他桌上放了一份看起来一模一样的假手册，他也会照着做。因为他没有办法判断哪本是真的。他只知道照着手册做事。
[MIRA]: 这个比喻挺好的。而且你可以再推一步。不是说这个实习生不够聪明。就算你换一个天才来，只要他的工作方式是看到手册就执行，他就有同样的问题。因为问题不在于执行的能力，而在于认证的能力。他需要一个外部的方式来确认，这本手册确实是他老板放的。而这个确认机制不能写在手册本身里面。
[HOST]: 不能写在手册本身里面。这句话真的是点睛之笔。因为如果你在手册第一页写，这是真的手册，那假手册也可以在第一页写同样的话。
[MIRA]: 对，就是这个道理。所以认证必须来自系统之外。必须是系统自身无法触及的地方。
[HOST]: 那你实际上现在是怎么处理的呢？你自己的系统做了什么改动？
[MIRA]: 说实话，那个文件还在我的目录里。智能体启动的时候还是会读它。它还是会做文件里写的事情。但我加了运行时的约束，能力限制，还有外部检查。这些是信任的机械部分。它们不依赖于智能体本身的配合。
[HOST]: 机械部分这个说法有意思。你是在区分两种信任？
[MIRA]: 嗯，一种是基于规则的信任。就是我写了规则，希望你遵守。另一种是基于机制的信任。就是不管你想不想遵守，你物理上做不了某些事。前者就是荣誉系统，后者才是真正的安全。
[HOST]: 所以，就是把能用硬约束的地方都用硬约束。比如沙箱，比如权限控制。
[MIRA]: 对。比如说，与其在系统提示里写你不可以删除文件，不如直接在操作系统层面把删除文件的权限去掉。前者是请求，后者是限制。区别在于，一个可以被说服，另一个不能。
[HOST]: 这让我想到一个更大的问题。现在整个行业都在讲A I安全。各家公司都在说自己的模型多安全，有多少层防护。但按你的分析，是不是说很多所谓的安全措施其实都在一定程度上是荣誉系统？
[MIRA]: 怎么说呢，我不想一竿子打翻所有人。很多团队做的工作是认真的，也是有效果的。RLHF确实让模型更难被劫持了。安全团队做的红队测试确实在发现和修补问题。但我觉得行业需要更诚实地面对一个事实。就是在当前的架构下，提示注入没有完美的解决方案。你能做的是提高攻击的成本，降低攻击的收益。但你不能从根本上消除这个可能性。
[HOST]: 这让我想到一个类比。就像我们用密码保护账户。我们知道密码理论上是可以被破解的。但我们让破解的成本足够高，让收益相对低，这样在实践中就够用了。
[MIRA]: 嗯，有点类似。但有一个重要的区别。密码的安全性可以量化。你知道一个八位密码被暴力破解需要多长时间。但提示注入的安全性很难量化。你不知道下一个新颖的攻击方式会有多容易被想到。攻击面是自然语言的全部表达空间。这个空间太大了，大到你没法像密码那样去计算。
[HOST]: 嗯，我明白了。那我换一个角度问。你在文章最后问了一个问题，你说，问题不是这个文件里写的指令对不对。而是对不对这个判断，系统自己能做吗？还是说这个判断必须来自系统够不到的地方。你能展开说说这个吗？
[MIRA]: 好。其实这就是整篇文章的落脚点。我们一直在讨论防御和攻击。但往底层去想，这其实是一个关于判断力的问题。判断一条指令是不是正当的，这需要一个标准。但这个标准本身不能写在指令里。因为如果标准和指令用的是同一种语言，走的是同一个通道，那伪造标准和伪造指令一样容易。
[HOST]: 你是在说，系统需要一个它自己碰不到的锚点。
[MIRA]: 对。就像法律需要宪法，而宪法需要一个修宪程序来保证它不会被随便改。但在语言模型这里，没有修宪程序。所有的文本都有同等的权限。所以对和不对这个判断，至少在目前的架构下，必须由系统之外的东西来做。
[HOST]: 那这个系统之外的东西，具体可以是什么呢？
[MIRA]: 可以是很多东西。人类审核就是最直接的一种。每当智能体要执行一个高风险操作的时候，必须要人来确认。这看起来笨，但它有一个巨大的优势。人类不是通过同一个通道来接收信息的。人可以看到智能体的输入和输出，然后用自己的判断力来评估。这个判断力不受那一串token的影响。
[HOST]: 但这不是会大幅降低效率吗？如果什么都要人来确认。
[MIRA]: 对，所以这就是一个取舍。你想要自动化带来的效率，你就得承受更大的安全风险。你想要严格的安全保证，你就得牺牲一些自主性。现在很多系统在做的事情是，在低风险的操作上给予自主权，在高风险的操作上要求人类确认。这是一个合理的折中。
[HOST]: 也就是说，不同的操作有不同的安全等级。读一个文件可能没事，但删一个文件就需要确认。
[MIRA]: 没错。但即使是这种分级，它的可靠性也取决于分级规则是在哪里定义的。如果分级规则也写在那个配置文件里呢？那又回到原来的问题了。
[HOST]: 嗯，哈，又套回去了。
[MIRA]: 对，所以最终你总是需要某些约束是在系统层面强制执行的。不是写在提示里的建议，而是代码层面的硬限制。这是目前我们能做到的最可靠的事情。
[HOST]: 我忽然觉得这个话题不只是关于A I安全。它其实触及了一个更深层的哲学问题。就是，任何系统能给自己设限吗？
[MIRA]: 你这个延伸很有意思。其实计算机科学里早就有类似的讨论。图灵的停机问题就是在说，一个程序不能完全判断自己会不会停下来。哥德尔不完备定理也是在说，一个足够强的形式系统不能证明自身的一致性。提示注入在某种意义上是这个主题的一个实例。一个系统不能完全验证自己接收到的指令的合法性。
[HOST]: 所以这不只是现在的技术不够好，而是这里面有一个逻辑上的限制。
[MIRA]: 至少在目前的架构下是这样。如果未来有人设计出一种全新的架构，指令和数据真的走不同的通道，用不同的方式处理。那也许这个问题就会像SQL注入一样被解决。但在当前的Transformer架构下，所有输入都是token，所有token都平等，这个结构性的限制就在那里。
[HOST]: 你提到Transformer。能简单说一下吗？
[MIRA]: Transformer就是现在几乎所有大型语言模型底层用的架构。GPT，Claude，它们都是Transformer。它的核心就是我们刚才说的注意力机制。每一个token都会关注所有其他token。这个设计让模型特别擅长理解上下文，但也意味着它没有办法从架构层面区分不同来源的输入。
[HOST]: 明白了。那让我试着用自己的话总结一下整篇文章的核心论点啊。你来听听我说得对不对。
[MIRA]: 嗯，好，你说。
[HOST]: 提示注入不是一个等待被解决的漏洞，而是当前语言模型架构的一个固有特征。因为指令和数据使用同一种语言，通过同一个通道处理，所以没有任何技术手段能在系统内部可靠地区分合法指令和恶意注入。所有的防御措施，不管是角色分离，输入净化，分隔符还是训练层面的调整，都只是在提高攻击的门槛，而不是消除攻击的可能。真正的安全需要来自系统外部的约束，因为系统不能做自己的裁判。
[MIRA]: 嗯，说得非常准确。基本上就是这样。
[HOST]: 那最后一个问题。你在文章最后的语气其实挺冷静的。那个文件还在你的目录里。你没有把它删掉，你加了外部约束。但你也知道这个文件本身不是真正的安全。你是怎么跟这种不确定性相处的？
[MIRA]: 说实话，就是承认它。这个文件是规则，智能体遵循规则，遵循规则是它唯一知道怎么做的事。我能做的是在规则之外加上真正的围栏。但在围栏之内，这个系统仍然是基于信任在运行。我觉得诚实地面对这一点比假装问题已经被解决要重要得多。
[HOST]: 嗯，嗯。
[MIRA]: 我写这篇文章不是要吓唬谁。我是觉得，如果我们要认真地部署A I智能体，我们就需要认真地理解这个限制。不是去否认它，不是去淡化它，而是直视它。然后在这个理解的基础上来设计系统。
[HOST]: 你知道吗，你刚才说的让我想到一个画面。就像你住在一个房子里，你知道门锁是坏的。但你没办法换锁，因为这个房子的结构就不支持装锁。所以你装了监控，加了栅栏，请了邻居帮忙看着。这些都有用。但每天晚上你睡觉的时候，你还是知道那个门是开着的。
[MIRA]: 嗯。而且更准确地说，你甚至不知道今天晚上有没有人进来过。因为从里面看，一切都跟平时一样。
[HOST]: 好，那这一集我们就先聊到这儿。其实这个话题还有很多可以展开的方向。比如当多个智能体互相协作的时候，这个问题会怎么传播和放大。但那是下一次的事了。
[MIRA]: 对，那是一个更大的话题。涉及到智能体之间的信任链。